[Music]
so happy that you're here after my
parents died and I didn't really think I
was gonna be able to come back to the
Hornet but you always made me feel like
family you are my family
[Music]
I'm Eric Thomas handle I just want to
find my friend I need you to do a favor
for me first you mess around I'll kill
you both
to park the car real close to the curb
you see you have to believe me they made
me do it the building that you blew up
the DEA safe house you know how long you
go away for unless you help us get Reno
Esparza
see the face
forget your friends no one's coming to
save you whether or not you survive
entirely up to you
so you gotta learn how to use one of
these illallah bullet balleseros
everything
ever since you surreal the police in one
step
you better do what you need to do Toledo
there's a mole in his operation
and I'm gonna come back my eyes hurt you
I'm not giving up on my family
lavalla in the end
the bullet service everything
the show
[Music]
you